mills the president's physician just
updated us on his progress saying the
president was doing
very well but sources close to the
president have concerns about how his
health is developing
joining us to break down this news and
more is jordan fabian bloomberg white
house reporter jordan thank you so much
for joining us on this
very hectic news day we appreciate it
glad to be here yeah thanks so jordan
can you just
tell me what we know right now from this
press conference and what you're hearing
from sources
yeah so we heard a very upbeat message
from the president's physician just a
few minutes ago from walter reed
national military medical center where
he's being treated saying the
president's condition
is good he hasn't needed oxygen today
his fever has gone down but then right
afterwards we heard from a high place
source close to the president that the
his condition over the last 24 hours
was very concerning uh prompting his
move to walter reed
and that the next 48 hours are critical
and that
it's not certain how this recovery is
going to go
so while we heard that again that upbeat
message
it's still uh not clear how well the
president
is going to recover from this virus
which of course has
killed over 200 000 americans
and tell me about the timeline here
because the president's medical team
mentioned
72 hours but previously had said the
diagnosis came 48 hours ago
and then issued a correction just
moments ago about
saying 72 hours so what is the timeline
here what are we looking at
right so it's another point of confusion
and this is a point i will say where we
really need precision and accuracy from
the president's medical team and this
and the white house staff and and
they're already having to clear up
some of these discrepancies we heard
from a white house official after this
press conference that
no you know the president was not
necessarily infected on wednesday
we're hearing that from the medical team
and other officials that
he had a pcr test which is the big long
swab that goes up your nose
on thursday and that that result was
reported
late thursday night which confirmed the
president's positive coven 19 diagnosis
and talk to me about treatment options
for the president um we know he's
received rem deserver what else do we
know about precautions being taken and
any treatments he's getting so far
right so he got a treatment of uh
by the company regeneron which uses a
combination of antibodies which is
thought to
help reduce the symptoms and reduce the
amount of time it takes to
suffer those symptoms that i will point
out that that treatment
has not received approval from the food
and drug administration nor has it
received
emergency use authorization it is in
trials
they've said they've had some positive
results and this is something that we're
told the president's
medical staff requested from generon and
that they
gave subsequently to the medical team at
the white house
on a quote-unquote compassionate use
request
so the president trying some
experimental treatments at this stage in
addition to
room desevere which has emergency youth
use authorization
we heard from sean connelly the white
house physician that his approach is
he doesn't want to leave anything off
the table he wants to try everything
possible
to try and treat the president and dr
sean connelly also mentioned that the
president is not
currently on oxygen and then kind of
hedged questions from reporters about
whether he had previously received any
oxygen
what are what are the white house pool
reporters thinking about this what is
the takeaway here is
has the president received any form of
oxygen
that's a great discrepancy you just
pointed out the the
sean conley the white house position was
a bit dodgy in answering that question
about
whether the president has at some point
received oxygen
he said that he didn't receive it on
thursday which is when he first tested
positive
or so we're told he said at one point
that he didn't receive it on friday but
then said
that he did not receive oxygen while at
walter reed on friday
and that puts that time frame after
6 30 p.m or so and then he said he
didn't receive it today
that leaves a window at the white house
when the president was there on friday
where he may have received it we don't
know if he did or not
but if the if we're going off the
information that we received
from that high place source that his
condition wasn't so great over the past
24 hours
then it's conceivable that he did but
again we don't have any confirmation
that he was on oxygen
at that stage what was your biggest
takeaway from this press conference
you've covered the white house for a
long time
what what is going through your head
right now as you're getting all this
news
well of course just the the magnitude of
the news that the president has tested
positive for kova 19 is just seismic i
mean this is a huge
huge deal the this is a implications
obviously for national security
for the campaign even for the supreme
court nomination process since a bunch
of other senators
have now tested positive but with this
news conference in particular
it goes back to the point that this
white house has
really struggled to give out accurate
and timely information about the
president's condition
we first learned that the president
tested positive you know late thursday
night
early friday and it took until saturday
morning for us to hear from the
president's physician
and then at that stage he was giving out
information that seemed
you know a bit dodgy that wasn't really
uh
so clear on on the oxygen point for
example if you wouldn't say
when the first president first tested
positive he wouldn't give out what the
president's temperature was
and of course the american people want
this information and we need it
to know you know how the president's
doing and what his condition is and to
make sure that he's
healthy and able to govern the country
and it's not
just president trump who has gotten this
diagnosis and several others in his
administration and just in his circle
more broadly
uh and it seems like we're getting a new
diagnosis every half hour here from
another individual uh but can you talk
me through
just some of the folks even from this
morning who have gotten a copy 19
diagnosis
yeah one that just came out right before
this press conference is new jersey
governor chris christie
he was obviously you wouldn't think that
this is this is a huge deal but
he was at the white house on saturday
for that confirmation or the nomination
event for amy coney barrett the
president supreme court nominee
so he was outside around 150 guests or
so
high-level white house officials uh
members of congress
conservative activists the president the
supreme court nominee and her family
he was also at the white house on sunday
for a news conference that the president
held
with reporters i was in the room for
that one he was sitting next to rudy
giuliani
that those two men were involved in
debate prep for the president behind
closed doors on sunday
then he was back at the white house on
monday so he had exposure to a lot of
people
high level people at the white house
including the president
and you know we're just again learning
that you know senator ron johnson tested
positive
this is someone who's you know key
republican senator i mean the list goes
on and on
i did learn uh today that rudy giuliani
the one who i just mentioned
uh actually tested negative yesterday so
um he's in the clear
as of right now but uh we're still have
a huge list of officials to go through
and of course
they'll be coming and getting tested in
the coming days to see if this is uh
something that is incubating and they
might test positive in the future
and you mentioned jordan uh judge amy
coney barrett's
uh confirmation ceremony i'm wondering
what
you are thinking about whether or not
this is classified as a super spreader
event given the amount of people we know
who
attended and are now positive
that's a great question it's it's hard
to say whether
that was the the triggering event that
that was the super spreader but it
certainly
looks like a lot of people who attended
that event have come down with
coronavirus
i will point out too that i mentioned
the debate prep
there are certain officials who are
involved in that debate
who ended up testing positive who were
not at the
saturday ceremony for amy coney barrett
uh bill stephen the president's campaign
manager
has tested positive we have learned he
was involved in debate prep not at that
event
so we're all still trying to figure out
what was
who was patient zero essentially and
what was the event
that sticking hope hicks and then the
president and whether those two cases
are related and in what way this is a
huge
massive contact racing endeavor the
president has been around
hundreds if not thousands of people if
you count his rallies and all the events
he's done
between last saturday and today so the
white house
uh and and others are still going
through this and trying to figure it out
and do we know whether or not trump was
tested the day
of the debate uh we know joe biden was
tested that day and was negative
um what happened with trump the day of
the debate
we still don't know we're told the
president is tested on a regular basis
we don't know if that meant daily up
until his diagnosis obviously
on thursday the we heard from chris
wallace that
debate site and therefore was not able
to
so uh they were he said something along
the lines of that they were relying on
the honor system that
he had in fact been tested and
jordan we are losing you a little bit so
i'm just going to update our viewers
here jordan was just explaining to us
that chris wallace mentioned
that donald trump did show up late to
the debate on wednesday and was not able
to get a coven 19 test
and therefore they kind of went by an
honor system essentially
um jordan if we still have you do you
want to elaborate on that a little more
i think we don't have jordan anymore uh
but for those yeah
i think okay jordan do we have you do
you want to update us on on the
what happened the date of the debate
yeah so yeah on the day of the debate
the president didn't show up in time to
get that test
at the cleveland clinic and so they were
relying on the honor system
according to chris wallace the debate
moderator so we don't know for sure if
he tested negative the day of the debate
jordan what has it been like for you
covering this uh you just mentioned that
you've been in the room
with several officials who've tested
positive for kovid
i'm wondering just as a reporter and a
human how
that impacts you and are you concerned
for your health
well thank you for asking about how i'm
doing i'm feeling fine right now
i tested negative yesterday i was at the
white house yesterday to cover
the president's departure for walter
reed so hopefully that continues to be
the case
but i'll point out that you know three
journalists at the white house have
tested
positive for kova 19. i think we're all
trying to
practice the health guidelines as much
as we can reporters who are covering the
white house
at the white house also on air force one
are wearing masks anytime that we're
doing that
we try to limit the number of reporters
who are showing up
to the white house to cover the
president not allowing the full
white house press corps in on any given
day but i will point out that for that
saturday event for amy coney barrett the
white house ended up credentialing
many more journalists than are usually
allowed under coven 19 restrictions
and so again that that event looks like
it could
be uh something that really has uh maybe
if not caused the spread
accelerated it to the wider republican
universe
absolutely jordan thank you so much for
your time this morning i know you've got
a very busy day covering this
breaking news for us so we will let you
go uh but for those of you watching you
can continue to get your updates on
this developing story by following
bloomberg quick take on all social
platforms wherever you get your news
and thank you so much for making time to
join us today
thanks appreciate marina